my beloved wife I've missed you terribly
thank you for returning lady Baldwin
safely now this mountain kneel before me
surrender army and proclaim me the true
Lord of Winterfell and warden of the
north I will pardon you for deserting
the Nights Watch I will pardon these
treasonous Lords for betraying my house
come bastard you don't have the men you
don't have the horses and you don't have
Winterfell
why lead those poor souls into sloth
there's no need for a battle
get off your horse Nia I'm a man of
mercy you're right there's no need for a
bow
thousands of men don't need to die only
one of us
listen this the old way you against me
I keep hearing stories about you bastard
the way people in the north talk about
you you're the greatest swordsman who
ever walked maybe you are that good
maybe not I don't know if I'd beat you
but I know that my army will beat yours
I have six thousand men you have what
half that not even high you have the
numbers will your men want to fight for
you when they're here you wouldn't fight
for them
he's good very good tell me will you let
your little brother die because you're
too proud to surrender how do we know
you have
now if you want to say you're going to
die tomorrow Lord Bolton sleepwalk
she's a fine woman your sister I look
forward to having her back in my bed and
you're all fine-looking men my dogs are
desperate to meet you I haven't fed them
for seven days a ravenous
I wonder which parts they'll try first
your eyes your balls
we'll find out soon in the morning then
bastard
you